Willkommen, Troy, ich bin so froh, dass wir dieses
Interview heute führen können.
Ja, danke, dass Sie
mich haben
äh, also ist es wirklich
großartig, einen Mitreisenden zu treffen und mit ihm zu sprechen
und vielleicht ein Publikum von
anderen Leuten zu erreichen, die uns genau ähnlich sind
, und ähm, ich meine, bevor wir uns
mit der Rolle von Bitcoins in der
Debatte über den Klimawandel befassen, möchten wir  zu wissen,
lass das Publikum wissen,
wer du bist, was du vor
Bitcoin gemacht hast, und vielleicht kannst du es kurz erklären,
äh ja, kurz ja,
ich bin ein akademischer Philosoph, das ist mein
Beruf oder Gewerbe,
ähm, und ich habe gelehrt  an einer Reihe von
Universitäten
in den USA und in Europa, und im
Moment unterrichte ich an einem kleinen
College für freie Künste im Pacific Northwest Reed
College, das ich wirklich liebe und genieße. Ich beschäftige
mich mit zeitgenössischer analytischer Erkenntnistheorie
und Metaphysik, äh nicht genau  im Zusammenhang
mit Bitcoin  aber alles hat auf die eine
oder andere Weise mit Bitcoin zu
tun, äh, das ist also mein Hintergrund im Training, ähm, ich,
ich war
mein ganzes, äh, erwachsenes Leben lang ein akademischer Philosoph, äh, das ist, was ich
tue,
äh, perfekt, ja, und es gefällt
Ihnen, was passiert ist, äh  Ihre
Interessen so sehr
geändert haben, weil Sie eine entscheidende Stimme
im Bitcoin-Bereich geworden sind und
viel Zeit damit verbringen, ist es möglich,
weil Sie plötzlich Bitcoin-reich geworden sind
oder was der Grund für
Ihre Interessenänderung ist
? Ich wünschte, ich wünschte, ich, ich  bin nicht reich äh
Bitcoin reich oder sonst äh mein Interesse
an Bitcoin ist eigentlich philosophisch und
ich habe Bitcoin von Anfang an
im Jahr 2011 entdeckt. Es hat
mich teilweise interessiert, weil
ich an diesen Elite-Universitäten gelehrt habe, an denen
meine Studenten später gearbeitet haben  für die Wall
Street etwas, von dem ich nicht wusste,
dass ich mich für das
Geldsystem interessierte, das Finanzsystem und
wirklich, ob es fair war, ob
es gerecht war, und ich
ahnte es  Es ist nicht nur, und je mehr ich
über das System erfuhr, desto ungerechter
fand ich es, äh, Bitcoin war
einfach die letzte von vielen Ideen
, die ich untersucht habe, einschließlich E-Gold, Sie
wissen schon, einschließlich Gold selbst, äh, als
Alternative zum Geldsystem  Wir
leben hier,
Sie wissen nicht, nicht als Teil meiner
offiziellen philosophischen Arbeit, aber Sie wissen, dass
ich eine neugierige Person bin
Als ich herausfand, was sie taten,
verstand sie nicht, wie diese
Branche wirklich einen Mehrwert brachte, und dann
sah ich natürlich, wie die Branche
2008 zusammenbrach. Ich sah, wie sie
gerettet wurde  war nicht wirklich
außergewöhnlich, aber das ganze System war darauf
ausgelegt, ein paar zu belohnen,
äh ja, das war der Beginn
meiner Reise, als Bitcoin auftauchte und ich
es 2011 entdeckte, wenn es das
fehlende Teil in einem Puzzle war, das ich war
bereits  zusammen und ich war
zu diesem Zeitpunkt im Jahr 2011 anonym. Ich war
auch besorgt über die Auswirkungen von Bitcoin auf
die Umwelt,
dass
ich schon früh ein paar Monate lang Bergbau betrieben habe, bevor
mir klar wurde,
dass ähm, wenn die Marktkapitalisierung von Bitcoin damals den Goldpreis erreichte,
ähm  würde enorme Mengen an
Energie
verbrauchen, und ja, ein Teil des Grundes, warum ich an
dieses College und nach Portland Oregon gezogen bin, war
mein Engagement für die Umwelt.
Portland ist ein Ort, an dem ich
ohne Auto und Fahrrad leben könnte, und Sie wissen, dass es in
Europa viele Städte gibt  wo man das
machen kann, aber nicht viele Städte, in denen man das machen kann.
In Amerika war Portland eine
davon
und ähm, ja, ich lebte autofrei. Ich
war ein Jahrzehnt Vegetarier. Ich war einen
Teil dieser Zeit Veganer, bis mein Körper einfach
nein sagte  Ich bin nicht sehr gut mit Veganismus umgegangen,
aber trotzdem war ich, äh, du
weißt schon, ich habe für gute Zwecke gespendet, aber ich war auch
aktiv dabei, Leuten an meinem College zu helfen
, über ihre Investitionen nachzudenken und
ob sie ethisch mit
Sus verbunden sind  Nachhaltigkeitsverpflichtungen gegenüber dem
College, so dass ich Bitcoin tatsächlich als
ein mächtiges Werkzeug für finanzielle Gerechtigkeit, aber
auch als Bedrohung für die Umwelt betrachtete, und ich
fand mich an dieser unangenehmen Stelle wieder, und
während ich
ja war, war ich von der Idee begeistert und ich war es
ab 2011 energisch an Online-Debatten teilgenommen, immer anonym.
Ich war auch
hin- und hergerissen über seinen potenziellen Erfolg. Mir wurde
klar, dass es die Umwelt nicht beeinträchtigte,
aber wenn es wirklich sein
wahres Potenzial entfaltet
, dann war ich 2011 ungefähr dort,
und das war genug  brachte mich dazu, mit dem Bergbau aufzuhören,
und verschenkte meine Mining-Maschinen
, äh, das waren im Grunde High-End-
Spielautomaten. Ich gab sie zur rechten Zeit an eine
lokale gemeinnützige Organisation,
wenn ich sie behalten
hätte, wäre ich reich, ja genau, aber ich
habe gehört, dass Sie gekauft haben  einige Alpakasocken
davon und äh ja, also hast du ja, ich
habe Alpakaaktien für fünf Bitcoins das
Stück gekauft, ein paar Dutzend Paare und äh, ich habe
viele andere, äh, kleine Einkäufe getätigt, äh,
als hätte ich Dinge gekauft  wie das Bitcoin-
Äquivalent von eBay handgemachte Waren Marmeladen
und Marmelade, als gäbe es nur sehr wenige
Dinge, die man kaufen könnte. Ich war nicht auf Drogen,
man konnte damals Drogen kaufen, aber
ich bin wirklich kein Drogenkonsument, also
war das nicht mein Ding, äh, aber  Ich habe versucht,
die Kreislaufwirtschaft zu unterstützen, und lassen Sie mich
nur
für Sie für Ihre Zuhörer, die
vielleicht Philosophen sind, die nicht verstehen,
warum dies etwas Wertvolles wäre,
lassen Sie mich einfach versuchen, ein Wort darüber zu sagen,
was Bitcoin ist und warum es
sich lohnt  Ein gerechteres System
Ich denke an Bitcoin in Bezug auf zwei
entscheidende Funktionen,
es ermöglicht Menschen, die eine
Internetverbindung haben, Wert an
jeden anderen auf der Welt zu senden, der eine
Internetverbindung hat,
also ist es ein Netzwerk zum Senden von
Werten,
und dieses Netzwerk ist es  nicht von einer zentralen Partei kontrolliert,
aber es ist dezentralisiert und
erlaubnisfrei und zensurresistent
und pseudonym,
also ist es im Grunde Peer-to-Peer-Geld, da
es Ihnen, wie Satoshi im Whitepaper sagt, ermöglicht, Werte Peer-to-P zu senden  eer
ohne Einmischung
direkt und die andere Sache, die es
tut, ist, dass es
Ihnen erlaubt, Vermögen auf eine Weise zu speichern,
die nicht anfechtbar ist. Es gibt eine feste Menge
an Bitcoin, die nach einem festen Zeitplan erhöht wird.
Jeder weiß, dass dieser
Zeitplan öffentlich ist und geteilt wird
äh, es wurde vom Schöpfer von
Bitcoin Satoshi Nakamoto eingerichtet, wurde nie
geändert und das
ermöglicht es Ihnen, auf ein Spargerät zurückzugreifen
, das nicht von einem Gelddrucker
entwertet werden kann, und das sind
wirklich zwei Merkmale, die Bitcoin hat, und
Sie würden denken  mögen denken, dass das keine
große Sache ist,
aber diese beiden Merkmale sind Merkmale, die
kein anderes Geldsystem hat, und sie stellen
auch dar, wie Geld von
Zentralbanken und Regierungen auf der
ganzen Welt missbraucht wird. Zentralbanken von Regierungen können
Zahlungen stoppen können Menschen aus dem
Finanzsystem heraushalten  Leute ausspionieren,
die Transaktionen durchführen oder Werte senden,
rechts, die sie irgendwie verbieten und
das Senden von Werten überwachen, und sie
erheben auch Gebühren  Nicht richtig, sie verlangen
dafür exorbitante Gebühren,
also sind das Möglichkeiten, die Nutzer
des Geldsystems auf der ganzen Welt zu
missbrauchen, und die andere Art, Geldnutzer zu missbrauchen,
besteht darin, ständig Geld zu drucken und
die Ersparnisse der Leute abzuwerten
ihrer Arbeit
und wir beginnen zu sehen, dass
in der jüngsten Inflationskrise, aber
es ist eine Realität für Milliarden von Menschen
auf der ganzen Welt und Hunderte von
Regierungen, dass ihr Geld
in exorbitanten
Raten
aufbläst, äh, das Leben der Menschen schwierig macht  Also im
Grunde
ist es ein Kompliment an die Schwächen
unseres Geldes. Es soll nicht heißen, dass es
großartiges Geld ist. Es soll nicht sagen, dass es
alles gut macht, aber es macht die Dinge
gut
Danke, ja
ja und ähm,
wie viele Leute jetzt kommen und
sagen, na ja, aber Bitcoin-Mining, äh, diese verschwenderische,
unnütze Sache verbraucht zu viel Energie, die
Sie zu dieser Art von Statistik sagen  Dass
es Energie verbraucht, es verbraucht eine beträchtliche
Menge an Energie, verbraucht derzeit
0,15 Prozent der gesamten Primärenergie.
Ob das viel oder wenig
ist, liegt im Auge des Betrachters, je
nachdem, ob Sie denken,
dass die Funktionen, die Bitcoin
der Menschheit bietet, eine  offenes monetäres
Netzwerk, das zig Millionen
Menschen dient, möglicherweise Milliarden von Menschen, von denen
Sie wissen, dass es
etwas mehr als ein Tausendstel aller Energie wert
ist. Ich denke, andere Leute sind anderer Meinung,
aber was noch wichtiger ist, die Frage, wie
viel Energie Bitcoin verbraucht, ist wirklich die
falsche Frage  nach dem Energieverbrauch zu fragen,
ist keine schlechte Sache, es ist nicht schädlich für
die Umwelt,
es hat nicht wirklich einen Nachteil,
ähm, manche Energieverbraucher schon und manche
nicht,
und das ist eine grundlegende
Einsicht, für die ich lange gebraucht habe  habe
auch
Bitcoin ist ein sehr einzigartiger
Energieverbraucher, tatsächlich ist es absolut einzigartig,
es gibt nichts
Vergleichbares. Zunächst einmal ist Mining das System
, das das Netzwerk, das es ist, sichert  Auch
auf der ganzen Welt verteilt, verbraucht
es Energie, um das Netzwerk zu sichern, so
dass, wenn jemand 51 der gesamten
Rechenleistung des Netzwerks erbeutet
, er Chaos im Netzwerk selbst anrichten
könnte, er es angreifen könnte und
daher mehr Energie in den
Dienst des Netzwerks gesteckt würde  Je sicherer das Netzwerk ist,
desto sicherer ist es,
aber wie wird diese Energie erzeugt, wenn diese
Energie aus der Verbrennung von Kohle und der
Stromerzeugung für den Betrieb von Bitcoin-
Minern stammt? Es ist sehr schädlich für die
Umwelt und die menschliche Gesundheit. Cole
ist eine
weniger schmutzige Quelle für Energiegas  Also Erdgas, aber es ist immer noch
eine umweltbelastende Form des Energieverbrauchs.
Andere Formen des Energieverbrauchs sind
jedoch nicht unbedingt umweltbelastend,
und hier können Sie an Wind
und Sonne und Wasserkraft denken,
aber selbst diese haben einen gewissen Fußabdruck,
äh, aber viel  der Energie, die
von Wind-Solar-Wasserkraft verbraucht wird,
ist eigentlich äh durch das Bitcoin-Mining-
Netzwerk eigentlich verschwendete Energie, also äh,
wir haben Bitcoin-Miner auf der ganzen Welt  d
konkurrieren, um jeden Tag eine begrenzte Menge
Bitcoin abzubauen, 900 Bitcoin pro Tag,
und äh, dieser Wettbewerb ist perfekt
, um Bergleute zu den billigsten Energiequellen zu treiben.
Die billigsten Energiequellen
sind nicht nur erneuerbar wie Wind, Wasserkraft,
Solarenergie, sondern auch
die Produktion  von der Energie,
die zeitlich oder räumlich am wenigsten benötigt wird,
damit Bitcoin-Miner
zu jeder Zeit und an jedem Ort der Welt zu jeder Zeit und an jedem
Ort der Welt im Grunde gleich viel Wohlstand aus Strom erzeugen, gibt es
skalierbare und ortsunabhängige zeitunabhängige Energieverbraucher  tragbar
, was passiert ist, dass
Sie vielleicht einen Solarpark haben
, der äh
20 Prozent seiner
Energie einschränkt  aber es ist tatsächlich
eine Zahlung
an den Solarproduzenten, die sie
sonst nicht erhalten würden, so
dass Solarabfall rentabel wird, wo
er nicht profitabel war  Nun, das ist Energieverbrauch,
aber es ist nicht schlecht für die Umwelt
, es ist sogar gut, weil plötzlich Solarenergie
jetzt profitabel ist und es unseren
Übergang zu
erneuerbaren Energien
beschleunigt  Eine andere Form der Energienutzung, die
gut für die Umwelt ist, ist das Verbrennen von
Abfallmethan. Methan ist die Ursache für
bis zu einem Drittel aller Erwärmungen. Es ist eine 84-
mal stärkere Erwärmung
eines Treibhausgases als CO2 über einen
Zeitraum von 20 Jahren
und
wenn, äh, Bitcoin-Miner  Gehen Sie zu abgelegenen
Orten, an denen Methan entweicht, wie
sagen wir, eine Deponie,
äh, Methan entweicht in die Atmosphäre,
und fangen Sie das Methan auf. Verbrennen Sie es. Sie
produzieren bei diesem Prozess CO2, aber sie
haben eine 84-fache Reduzierung über einen kürzeren
Zeitraum bei a erreicht  25-fache Reduzierung
über einen längeren Zeitraum von 100 Jahren, ähm,
in Treibhausgasen, ähm, Erwärmungspotential,
richtig, also ist die Verwendung von abgelassenem Methan, um das Minennetz mit Strom zu versorgen,
Energieverbrauch,
aber
das ist es  Das Netto-CO2-Äquivalent ist negativ in seiner
Erwärmungswirkung, richtig, also diese beiden
Formen des Energieverbrauchs, und das soll nur
an der Oberfläche kratzen, aber es gibt
Ihnen eine Vorstellung von dem Kaninchenbau, in dem
ich diese beiden Formen des Energieverbrauchs gesehen habe
könnte den Energieverbrauch von Bitcoin in die Höhe treiben
,
könnte aber netto positiv für die
Umwelt sein
und äh ja, das Bild
wird komplizierter, aber das ist das
Wesentliche
ist das
nicht per se schlecht, dass der Energieverbrauch
aus ökologischer Sicht gut oder schlecht sein kann,
je nachdem, wie er
annimmt, und es gibt positive Formen des
Energieverbrauchs für die Umwelt,
ja, also das war, äh, das ist es, was
mir so aufgefallen ist  viel, wenn ich mich
hinsetze und all Ihre Posts lese und
Sie auch Ihre Gespräche gehört haben,
ähm, dass Sie nicht nur
entlarven, warum Bitcoin schlecht für die
Umwelt ist, sondern tatsächlich sagen, dass
es s hat  om gut wie ein Vorteil für die
Umwelt und ähm, das ist wirklich
kontraintuitiv, wenn Sie anfangen zu
ähm ja, wenn Sie anfangen, über diesen Raum zu lesen
, wenn Sie anfangen, über Bitcoin zu lesen,
ähm, und ich versuche, diesen
Punkt oft zu machen, aber  Dann ist da noch diese
Sache, also sagten wir, okay, Bitcoin ist nicht
nutzlos, es hat ähm, es ist gerechtfertigt,
überhaupt Energie zu verbrauchen, also ist es selbst keine Verschwendung,
dann sagen wir, okay, es ist nicht einmal, es ist
der effizienteste Energieverbraucher da draußen
, den es braucht  finde die
billigste und äh nachhaltigste
Energiequelle, um auf lange Sicht zu überleben
und so haben wir diese beiden
Schecks bekommen und dann ist der letzte Punkt
vielleicht ein Argument, das viele Leute gut bringen,
aber es nimmt dir die
Energie wie Bitcoin  findet, warum verwenden wir es nicht
für andere Häuser wie für Haushalte für
andere Anwendungsfälle, was sagen Sie dazu,
wie warum können wir diese Kreativität
aus dem Bitcoin-Raum nicht nutzen
, um Energie für den Alltag zu schaffen?
Ich denke, es ist kurz
Bitcoin  wi  Ich werde ein Teil des
Energieverbrauchs für das tägliche Leben sein und äh, ich,
ich denke, äh, gehen wir zurück zu der
Beobachtung. Es tut mir leid, dass ich mich ein bisschen schnell bewegt habe
Markt mit perfektem Wettbewerb, was bedeutet, dass jeder Bitcoin-
Minderjährige genau die gleiche
Aktivität ausübt, in der er Strom
verbraucht, und er bekommt Bitcoin mit der gleichen Rate heraus,
weil er die gleichen Maschinen betreibt
, um für Sie und
das, was er bekommt, profitabel zu sein  out ist identisch, dass alle
Bitcoin-Hersteller dieses fungible
Gut produzieren, das sofort
über das Internet um die ganze Welt verschickt wird,
sozusagen,
ähm, nichts unterscheidet Bitcoin,
das an einem Ort produziert wird, von Bitcoin,
das an einem anderen produziert wird, also ist
es vollkommen wettbewerbsfähig, was bedeutet, wenn
Sie irgendwo billigeren Strom finden können
Auf der ganzen Welt liegen Ihre Kosten unter denen anderer
Hersteller und
die Margen des Bitcoin-Minings
schrumpfen immer weiter, so dass Sie schließlich
andere Miner aus dem Geschäft drängen werden  Richtig
, das ist also der grundlegende Mechanismus: ein
perfekter Markt. Der perfekteste Markt
, der jemals existiert hat
, kommt einem Wirtschaftslehrbuchbeispiel für einen
perfekten Markt am nächsten,
weil es sich um ein digitales
fungibles Gut handelt, dessen Input nur
Strom ist
, was bedeutet, dass die Preissensibilität extrem ist
Um Bitcoin profitabel zu
schürfen, müssen Sie im Moment weniger als fünf Cent
pro Kilowattstunde Stromkosten haben,
und es ist wahrscheinlich niedriger,
es sind eher vier Cent pro Kilowattstunde
und
in Ordnung, und sehr bald wird das
noch weiter nach rechts fallen  Es wird
in naher Zukunft leicht auf zwei Cent oder eineinhalb Cent pro Kilowattstunde sinken
, da die
gesamte Netzwerkleistung wirklich
schnell steigt und die Belohnung dennoch genau gleich bleibt.
Was bedeutet das, wenn
Sie nichts verdienen können?  Geld
schürfen auf alles andere als zwei drei Cent pro
Kilowattstunde Strom, das ist viel weniger
als Einzelhandelsverbraucher
zahlen überall und überall richtige Einzelhandelspreise  sind höher
als das, sie sind sehr oft subventioniert
und noch viel höher als das. Tatsächlich sind die
kommerziellen Tarife höher als das,
wo Sie Strom bekommen können, der weniger als
fünf Cent pro Kilowattstunde kostet,
im Grunde nur dort, wo es
keine konkurrierende Nachfrage nach Strom gibt
Sie können diese Tarife nicht
außerhalb von New York City oder Los Angeles
oder Berlin bekommen oder sonst wo in Sie kennen
keine große Stadt auf der Welt oder irgendeine Stadt
in ähm in Europa, die nicht 300
400 K nördlich von ähm ist. Sie wissen, wo,
wo ist, wo ist das  Bergbau findet in
Europa statt Hydro in Nordnorwegen,
äh, es ist mehrere hundert Meilen nördlich von,
äh, von Oslo und im Moment nicht
ausreichend an das Stromnetz angeschlossen. Bergleute
an diesem Ort zahlen 1,5
Cent pro
Kilowattstunde, das ist der Preis, den sie
zahlen  Leute in Oslo, was sie
für Strom bezahlen, es ist gerade sehr teuer,
wir befinden uns in einer Energiekrise,
richtig, das gilt weltweit überall dort
, wo Energie
B knapp wird  Itcoin-Miner werden nicht da sein, weil diese Krise
ihr Geschäft unrentabel machen würde, also ist dies
ein unglaublicher Energieverbraucher
, der nur mit den billigsten Energieformen weltweit überleben kann,
was bedeutet, dass er
niemals zu einer Energiekrise beitragen sollte
und doch gleichzeitig  Wenn sein
Energieverbrauch bezahlt wird und dieser
Schmerz für Energie subventioniert den
Ausbau der Energieproduktion, die sehr
billig ist, subventioniert es nicht viel,
weil sie nur zahlen, wissen Sie, dass
sie nur zwei Cent zahlen werden
eine Kilowattstunde, aber es ist mehr als null
und äh, also muss man sich fragen, welche
Energieformen zu
diesen sehr, sehr günstigen Preisen Strom produzieren können, und wir haben im
Moment einfach Glück, dass Solarenergie
die billigste Form der neuen Energieerzeugung
ist  tatsächlich jetzt billiger und das ist
natürlich regional unterschiedlich es ist billiger
, Energie mit Solarenergie zu erzeugen es baut eine
ganz neue Solaranlage
dann ist es einfach, Gasanlagen im Allgemeinen zu betreiben,
das ist die Analyse von  Lazard
mag, dass die Grenzkosten für den Betrieb eines
Gaskraftwerks, nicht einmal unter Berücksichtigung seiner
Infrastruktur,
mehr sind als der Bau neuer Solaranlagen, und
das gleiche gilt für Kohle
sich jemals
zusammenzuschließen,
ähm, Atomkraft hatte es schwer
, ihre Versprechen zu halten, aber möglicherweise
könnte es sehr billiger Strom sein, und Bitcoin
passt sehr gut zu nuklearem, ähm, also wird
Bitcoin dazu beitragen, einen
Käufer dieser supergünstigen Energiebasis
zu schaffen  ihre Rentabilität, ohne
die Stromrechnung von irgendjemandem zu erhöhen,
das ist die Magie von Bitcoin als
Verbraucher. Es wird niemals mit dem Einzelhandel konkurrieren, es
sei denn, wir befinden uns zufällig in einem Moment, in dem
die Mining-Maschinen knapp sind und
der Preis von Bitcoin gestiegen ist  enorm
und das geschah tatsächlich vor zwei
Jahren, und wir hatten Bitcoin-Miner
, die in Zertifikatsgemeinschaften wie in
Upstate New York zogen
, wissen Sie, Onmas,
als min  ing in China verboten wurde, hatten wir
es in einem Moment, in dem es plötzlich
rentabel war, Bitcoin mit Energie zu jedem beliebigen Preis
abzubauen,
und wir hatten bestimmte Fälle von Bitcoin-
Minenarbeitern, die Kohlekraftwerke offen hielten,
die sonst geschlossen worden wären, und Gaskraftwerke offen hielten, die sonst geschlossen worden
wären  wurde geschlossen und trieb die lokalen
Versorgungspreise in die Höhe, im
Grunde weil der Bergbau aus China nach Amerika geflohen ist,
wo sich die Hälfte des Bergbaus zu
der Zeit während eines Bullenlaufs befand,
in diesem einen Moment trieb der Bitcoin-Bergbau die
Versorgungspreise vor Ort in die Höhe und verhinderte auch,
dass fossile Anlagen
stillgelegt wurden
und  Also hat Bitcoin dieses Potenzial und
in diesen seltenen Momenten, aber es ist wahr, dass
es ein langfristiger Trend ist,
nur auf die billigste Energie zu setzen, um
als Verbraucher nicht konkurrenzfähig zu sein und erneuerbare und kohlenstoffarme Energieformen zu verbrauchen und zu betreiben
Produktion und um verschwendete Energie zu monetarisieren,
und genau das sehen wir jetzt,
also denke ich, dass die Welt
über das Energieprofil von Bitcoin verwirrt ist, gerade
weil es gedauert hat  eine Momentaufnahme dessen, was
Bitcoin zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt tat,
und dann verallgemeinerte es, dass vorwärts,
äh ja, das ist auch das, was ich
Sie fragen wollte, im Grunde, äh, die langfristige
Tendenz, die Sie irgendwie auch schon
beschrieben haben, aber hier ist eine Aussage
Außerdem wird oft behauptet, je
mehr Bitcoin angenommen wird und je
größer ja, desto höher
die Preise, desto höher der Energieverbrauch.
So nett zu Ihrer Annahme, die
Sie 2011 hatten, dass es im Grunde nie
einen Energieverbrauch stoppen wird,
ähm und ähm  Ich habe das Gefühl, dass es geht oder
wenn es vergisst, dass es eine
Anpassung des Schwierigkeitsgrades und all diese
Dinge gibt, aber ich frage mich,
wie Sie auf diese Behauptung antworten würden.
Ja, zunächst einmal, wenn der Preis
steigt, gibt es mehr Anreize für mich
Das ist wahr und ähm, ein sehr schneller Anstieg des
Preises wird mehr Mining schaffen
und wir haben das gesehen und wir haben das in der
gesamten Geschichte von Bitcoin gesehen,
ähm,
aber wie Sie sagen, es gibt dieses Ding namens
da ist das Problem  lty-Anpassung,
aber es gibt diese Sache, die als
Bitcoin-Ausgabeplan bezeichnet wird,
äh, es geht so, dass diese neuen
Bitcoin an Bergleute vergeben werden, äh, alle etwa 10
Minuten, wenn ein neuer Block hinzugefügt wird, ein neuer
Eintrag zum gemeinsam verteilten Ledger
von Bitcoin und zusammen mit jedem Block, äh
Der siegreiche Miner erhält
eine Blocksubvention,
als Bitcoin zum ersten Mal erstellt wurde.
Diese Blocksubvention betrug 50 Bitcoin pro Block.
50 Bitcoin alle 10 Minuten. Das war, als
ich schürfte, und das war, als ich diese
Berechnungen
anstellte. 50 neue Bitcoin wurden alle 10
Minuten
ausgegeben  Zeitplan halbiert sich alle
vier Jahre, also vier Jahre nach
Einführung des Protokolls fiel
die Blockbelohnung von 50 auf
25 pro 25 Bitcoins, die pro 10 Minuten vergeben wurden,
dann fiel sie auf 12,5 und dann
wieder auf 6,25, das ist die Epoche, in der
wir uns befinden, und zwar bald  es wird auf
3.125 uh fallen und so von 900 Bitcoin pro
Tag auf 450 pro Tag steigen. Dies ist der Zeitplan
für die Ausgabe von Bitcoin alle vier
Jahre und 99
9  8 bis 99 aller Bitcoin-Minereinnahmen stammen
aus dieser Blocksubvention. Die restlichen
ein bis zwei Prozent stammen aus Gebühren, die
zu diesem Zeitpunkt vernachlässigbar sind. Im
Grunde genommen sind die Belohnungen von Bitcoin für
Miner weltweit
in Bitcoin-Bedingungen so konzipiert, dass sie mit
dieser exponentiellen Rate sinken, um
Bitcoin-Mining zu ermöglichen  Der Anreiz,
den Preis von Bitcoin zu erhöhen, muss sich alle vier Jahre verdoppeln,
und dann müssen wir ein gewisses Recht darauf haben, dass sich der Preis
alle vier Jahre mehr als verdoppelt, und tatsächlich hat sich
die Geschichte der Preise von Bitcoin
alle vier Jahre mehr als verdoppelt
Deshalb ist der Anreiz für Minderjährige gewachsen
und es ist eine außergewöhnliche Wachstumsrate,
aber wie lange kann eine solche Wachstumsrate
anhalten,
ähm, eigentlich nicht mehr lange, ähm
, wenn Sie daran denken, den
Preis von Bitcoin zu verdoppeln, ähm alle vier
Jahre, nur was zu verdoppeln  würde bedeuten
, den Anreiz,
Energie zu verbrauchen, gleich zu halten, äh, Sie treffen sehr
schnell die Gesamtmenge
aller Gelder der Welt, in Ordnung, es ist
so  Mething wie 20 äh, wissen Sie, 25 Jahre
26 Jahre, wir werden ganz oben sein, wenn
wir mit dieser Wachstumsrate des Preises fortfahren,
würde der Wert von Bitcoin dem Geld entsprechen,
dem Wert von allem Geld auf der Welt,
also gibt es keine so große Obergrenze
Die Leute machen das zunächst nicht,
äh, aber das andere, was
daran irreführend ist, ist, äh, dass ich denke, dass
der Energieverbrauch von Bitcoin weiter steigen wird,
selbst wenn die Blockbelohnung, die
Blocksubvention, die an die Bergleute geht, sinkt, damit wir
unsere Energie haben  Budget und dann haben wir, wie
viel Energie wir mit diesem Budget bekommen,
und ich denke, dass das Energiebudget,
selbst wenn der Preis nicht wächst, selbst
wenn das Energiebudget schrumpft, die Energie
, die wir mit demselben Budget verbrauchen
, wachsen wird, weil Bitcoin  Bergleute
suchen und finden im Grunde
billige Energie auf der ganzen Welt,
also zahlen sie immer weniger für
ihre Energie, so wie vor zwei Jahren wahrscheinlich
der durchschnittliche Betrag, der für Energie bezahlt
wurde, wahrscheinlich 10 Cent pro Kilowattstunde betrug,
nur gi  Obwohl die Leute
überall eingesteckt haben, sind es jetzt vier und in zwei weiteren
Jahren werden es zwei sein, und danach
wird es eins sein, und in einem Jahrzehnt wird
es sehr nahe bei Null sein,
etwas anderes, was wir bei
Bitcoin sehen  Mining ist Bitcoin-Miner, die
Energie in Wärme umwandeln. Letztendlich wird die Energie,
die in Form von Strom in einen Bitcoin-Miner
gelangt
, gespeichert, sie geht nirgendwo hin, sie wird nur zu einer anderen
Energieform, einer weniger nützlichen Form von
minderwertiger Wärme, und Bitcoin-Miner verwenden
diese  Wärme, die sie tatsächlich verkaufen,
äh, die großen, du kannst sie verwenden,
um dein Haus zu heizen, einige der großen
Bergleute verwenden diese Energie für
verschiedene industrielle Prozesse, äh
, sagen wir, in Papierrechnungen oder beim Trocknen von
Holz oder in der Fermentation, die einige verwenden
sie, um Gewächshäuser zu heizen, um
Blumen anzubauen, um Lebensmittel in Nordeuropa anzubauen,
äh, aber auch Fernwärme,
aber wir werden mehr und mehr
Anwendungen für minderwertige Wärme finden,
und wenn Sie dann Geld für Ihre
Wärme bekommen  Sie können tatsächlich mehr
als einen Bitcoin ausgeben, um einen Bitcoin abzubauen,
weil Sie auch in Wärme bezahlt werden,
also sind Sie immer noch profitabel, richtig, Sie werden
Ihre Schulden bezahlen, ja, und
das haben wir gerade, ich meine, es ist das
erste Mal  In Europa
kämpfen wir mit den Kosten für Wärme und
dergleichen und auch für Strom, aber äh, es ist
das erste Mal, dass ich das Gefühl habe, dass wir die
Möglichkeit haben, die
Anpassungsfähigkeit von Bitcoin in alltäglichen
Anwendungsfällen zu verstehen. Ja,
genau das, wenn es um elektrische
Heizung geht, äh sogar  Obwohl die gesamte
Energie in Bitcoin Miner eingespart wird, ist
es immer noch nicht die effizienteste Heizung,
es ist eine Widerstandsheizung, es ist keine
Wärmepumpe,
aber bei sehr kaltem Wetter
sind Wärmepumpen unzureichend und sie
können ergänzend zu Widerstandsheizungen verwendet werden,
was wichtig ist  dass die
Elektrifizierung richtig ist, wenn Sie kein
Gas haben, aber Ihr Gas ist sehr
teuer, aber Sie haben Strom,
weil Ihr
Strom mit Offshor erzeugt wird  Der Wind oder die Kernenergie
oder
andere Formen erneuerbarer oder
kohlenstoffarmer Energie,
dann wenn Sie wissen, dass Wärme einer der
Hauptverbraucher fossiler Brennstoffe ist, wenn
Sie von dieser auf Elektrizität umsteigen und Ihr
Mix besser als 100 fossil ist, richtig
Sie machen  ein Nettovorteil, und wenn
Sie mit Wärmepumpen arbeiten, sind noch bessere
Wärmepumpen auch eine Menge
Kapitalaufwand für die Installation, also
sehe ich die Bitcoin-Heizung als wirklich eine
wichtige Veränderung in ihrer Rolle, aber
stellen Sie sich jetzt vor, Sie hätten eine Bitcoin-Heizung
Überall dort, wo wir minderwertige elektrische
Industriewärme haben, die wir mit
Wärmepumpen usw. verwenden,
wird Bitcoin eine Tonne Energie verbrauchen,
da im Wesentlichen die Energie verwendet wird
, die wir gerade für die
Widerstandsheizung verwenden, das ist viel mehr
Energie als die  Das Bitcoin-Mining-Netzwerk
verwendet Heizung und macht einen großen Prozentsatz des
gesamten Energieverbrauchs aus,
daher würde ich sehen, dass der Energieverbrauch von Bitcoin gerade
in den Himmel steigt,
aber
das Budget für Energie für Bitcoin-Energie
in Bitcoin-Begriffen ist sehr klein und auch
t  Das Emissionsprofil zusammen mit diesem
Energieverbrauch ist sehr gering, weil es
einfach die vorhandene Heizung ersetzt,
also ist es eine Netto-Dekarbonisierung, um noch
einmal auf die Frage von Energie
und Emissionen zurückzukommen.
Wir sehen eine Zukunft, in der der Energieverbrauch von Bitcoin
außergewöhnlich ist, aber
niemandem hinzugefügt wird  Rechnung, es trägt
nicht zu den CO2-Emissionen bei, tatsächlich ist
es netto CO2-negativ, es
ersetzt fossile Heizung, es
ersetzt andere Formen der
elektrischen Heizung,
äh, es macht Geld,
äh, es macht neue erneuerbare Energien zu Geld
und beschleunigt den Übergang zu
erneuerbaren Energien und trägt zur
Elektrifizierung der Wirtschaft bei
Richtig, äh, das ist der grundlegende Irrtum
, der Emissionen und Energie verwechselt, und dies
ist nur ein weiteres Beispiel dafür, wie ich sehe, wie
diese beiden großartig auseinandergehen,
wie Troy, das ist meiner Meinung nach so auf den
Punkt, dass ich wirklich
mitmachen könnte, und ich denke, Sie haben es
wirklich geschafft  guter Punkt, um diese
Dinge zusammenzufassen, diese Themen, also hoffe ich das wirklich
Art gibt dem Publikum ein besseres
Verständnis dafür, wie es funktioniert,
ähm, was und wenn sie interessiert sind, ähm, ich
empfehle ihnen wirklich,
sich Ihren Podcast mit Peter
McCormack anzusehen, in dem es darum geht, wie gut Bitcoin
für die Umwelt ist, Sie
erklären Ihre Idee
Ähm, wirklich gut, ich denke darüber nach, wie
Bitcoin kann. Sie wissen auch, wie die
längere Version dessen, was wir gerade im
Grunde genommen haben, und
ähm, ja, aber ich so so für das Ende des
Interviews, ich wollte Ihnen irgendwie
den Raum geben Auch für vielleicht etwas hinzuzufügen
zu deiner Vorstellung, wie Bitcoin gut
für die Umwelt sein kann, wenn du noch nicht alles gesagt hast
und wenn nicht, dann vielleicht
auch die neue Idee, was du
auf der Bitcoin
Pacific uh Konferenz so mitgebracht
hast  Sag ja, ich habe noch
nicht ganz gesagt, wie Bitcoin-Mining sein könnte
oder warum ich denke, dass
es ein Nettoguthaben sein könnte.
Ich habe gesagt, dass Sie wissen, dass Heizung
durch Mining ersetzt werden
könnte  Bui anregen  ld aus
erneuerbaren Energien und helfen,
erneuerbare Energien rentabel zu machen, und ich habe gesagt, dass
es uns helfen kann, mit
Abfallmethan richtig umzugehen, aber äh, an dem Punkt
, den ich in Peters Podcast gemacht habe und
den ich hier machen sollte, ist, dass
Bitcoin gerade jetzt ist  zu klein,
um tatsächlich einen bedeutenden Unterschied
in beide Richtungen zu machen, wirklich in die
negative oder in die positive Richtung auf
der negativen Seite. Cambridge schätzt, dass
Bitcoin
derzeit für 0,09 Prozent der
Emissionen der Erwärmung verantwortlich ist, was bekanntlich
negative Auswirkungen auf die Umwelt hat, aber
es ist so  wirklich klein, es sind weniger als ein
Tausendstel der Emissionen, und natürlich ersetzt
es das Legacy-
Finanzsystem, das seine eigenen
Auswirkungen hat, es ersetzt Aktien,
die kohlenstoffintensiver sind, äh, äh, Stückwert,
was wir in der Zukunft sehen müssen
Für Bitcoin Mining ist es eine viel
größere Operation, um einen
positiven Einfluss zu haben, der bedeutsam ist, ich meine
die Subventionen
von Solar in Califor  nia allein sind viel
viel größer als die gesamte Bitcoin-
Mining-Industrie, richtig viel größer
als die gesamte Industrie, nur bei einer
staatlichen Subvention allein, also reicht es
wirklich nicht aus, um einen bedeutenden
Unterschied in beide Richtungen zu machen,
he, es muss viel größer sein und
die Idee  die ich mit
Andrew Bailey darüber entwickelt hatte,
wie man den Prozess des Ausbaus des Bitcoin-Mining beschleunigen kann,
und seine Auswirkungen
für immer. Seine Auswirkungen sind
wahrscheinlich netto negativ auf die Umwelt,
obwohl sie sehr gering sind, sie tendieren in
diese positive Richtung, wie bekommen wir das hin?
um dort schneller zu tendieren und wie wir
es auf die Größe skalieren können, die erforderlich ist, um einen
positiven und bedeutsamen Unterschied zu machen
Das heißt, wenn Sie Bitcoin halten,
äh, einen bestimmten Prozentsatz aller
Bitcoin, sagen wir, null, ein
Prozent aller Bitcoin, lautet unser Rezept, dass Sie
null tun sollten  ein Prozent aller
Schürfungen Ihr Beitrag zum
Bitcoin-Mining-Netzwerk sollte Ihrem
Besitz von Bitcoin entsprechen, der Vermögenswert sollte mindestens
gleich sein, und dieser Beitrag zur Hash-Rate
sollte sozial positiv und klimaneutral
oder negativ sein, wenn Sie
etwas Schürfen auf Abfall betreiben  Methan sind Sie netto
kohlenstoffnegativ und wenn Sie genug davon tun
, gleicht es den Anreiz aus, den Sie
Bergleuten weltweit mit dem
Bitcoin geben, das Sie halten, ja, diese Idee, äh,
Andrew und ich präsentieren in einem Papier,
das auf der Andrew-Site Resistance
Dot Money verfügbar ist  Slash Green uh Resistance Dot
Money Slash Greens, wo Sie diese Idee lesen können
, also ja, nur um einen Schritt zurück zu sein. Ich
denke, Bitcoin muss als Vermögenswert
und als Netzwerk wachsen, um einen bedeutenden Unterschied zu machen,
es muss auch
eher früher seine endgültige Form erreichen, um einen bedeutenden Unterschied zu machen
als später und ich denke, wir können eine
Rolle spielen. Bitcoin ist nur ein Open-Source-
Protokoll. Wir sind Teil einer Community. Warum
habe ich mich engagiert,
weil Bitcoin kein Unternehmen ist?  Es ist
kein Unternehmen, es gibt keinen CEO, weil
es nur wir sind, und ich
weiß das seit 2011, es ist ein Open-Source-Protokoll, das
Sie auf Ihrem Computer ausführen können, aber es ist auch eine
Gemeinschaft von Menschen, die die
Zukunft dieses Codes und seiner
Implementierung gestalten  Die Welt Bitcoin ist eine
Gemeinschaft, es ist eine offene, erlaubnisfreie
Gemeinschaft, aber es ist immer noch eine Gemeinschaft, und
wenn Sie Bitcoin gestalten möchten, können
Sie Ihre Idee für seine
Zukunft präsentieren und sich dann dafür einsetzen, und
das habe ich getan, äh, ich habe den Raum betreten, in dem
ich eine Idee hatte  Ich setze mich dafür ein, aber
ich setze auch mein Geld dafür ein, dass ich
versuche, mich um mich selbst zu kümmern und andere,
die meine Werte teilen, dazu zu bringen, auch auf ihre
Art abzubauen. Dieser Bitcoin ist nicht etwas, das Sie
nur von außen beobachten müssen  wie
alles andere auf dieser Welt und
sagen Sie einfach, oh mein Gott, die Welt wird zur Hölle,
Sie wissen, oh mein Gott, die Umwelt
wird zerstört, oh mein Gott, große
Konzerne verschmutzen und sie ziehen
Wert aus der
Welt  l South und was auch immer das
Erbe von Köln fortsetzt, müssen wir
das mit Bitcoin nicht tun. Wir sind Bitcoin, das ist
der Unterschied.
Sie sind Teil dieses monetären Netzwerks
Sehen Sie, was Sie geändert haben möchten, treten Sie einfach
ein und machen Sie einen Unterschied,
machen Sie selbst einen Unterschied, und das war
meine Botschaft,
als müssten wir nicht passiv hier sitzen
und zusehen, wie der
Bergbau in eine Richtung geht, von der wir nicht wollen, dass er
geht  Kostenlose und erlaubnisfreie Aktivität
Jeder kann einen Asic kaufen Jeder kann
ihn anschließen und Sie wissen, dass es so viele
europäische Bitcoiner gibt, die
Miner als Heizungen anschließen, die sie auf ihrem
eigenen Solarrecht betreiben, und wenn sie das tun
, erhöhen sie die Hash-Rate und  Sie bekommen
einen Teil dieser begrenzten 900 Bitcoin pro Tag,
was es für die Leute teurer und schwieriger macht
, andere vier
Energiequellen abzubauen, und das ist schön, das ist meine
Idee, richtig, das ist ein Netzwerk, das wir besitzen
, machen wir es so, wie wir es wollen  Sei
Das ist so toll. Ich meine, eine praktische
Frage, die ich hier habe, ist, dass Sie
gut klettern könnten. Es ist so teuer, die
Infrastruktur eines Asic zu bekommen. Sie kaufen den
S19, der kostet jetzt ungefähr 5.000
Euro oder etwas, vielleicht weniger oder mehr,
wie viel mehr  wie 2500
, wirklich ich, es war so viel billiger,
weil der äh Tipp,
der Preis von Bitcoin, der in der
Hash-Rate gesunken ist, Asics billiger gemacht hat,
was großartig ist, weil äh, das bedeutet,
dass Sie im Budget des
Bergbaus nicht arbeiten  Sie müssen so viel
Betriebszeit für Ihre Maschine haben, um
rentabel zu sein, weil Sie weniger
Abschreibungen haben. Stattdessen
ist Energie Ihr
wichtigster Input
immer noch teuer und s19s sind schwierig
zu betreiben,
sie sind laut,
äh, sie sind nicht, es ist nicht einfach, sie zu
Hause mit einer Maschine der neuesten Generation abzubauen, und deshalb habe
ich daran gearbeitet, wie Sie Ihre
Werte, wie wir sie nennen, abbauen können,
ohne einen Mach zu besitzen  Ich bin bei Ihnen zu Hause
und es gibt ein paar Möglichkeiten, dies zu tun. Eine
davon ist gehostetes Mining mit der richtigen Art
von Hosting. Ich arbeite mit einem Unternehmen zusammen,
ähm, SAS-Mining, von dem Sie wissen, dass
es ausschließlich für erneuerbare Energien geht
, die gerade eröffnet werden  Ihre erste Anlage
Natürlich ist es eine sehr schwierige Zeit,
ein Bergbauunternehmen zu leiten, aber sie stehen
kurz vor der Eröffnung ihrer ersten Anlage auf
Hydro Small Hydro im Mittleren Westen der
USA.
Eine Sache, die Sie tun könnten, wäre, eine
Maschine zu kaufen und sie zu haben  von jemand anderem gehostet wird,
von jemand anderem ausgeführt wird, und Sie
geben ihm einen Anteil an den Gewinnen
dafür, da wir alle wissen, dass das heikel ist, dass Sie
Ihre eigenen Nachforschungen anstellen müssen, weil Sie
keinen eigenen Computer haben,
aber das andere Ding ich '  Ich arbeite an einem
Hash-Rate-Produkt, bei dem Sie im Wesentlichen
das Recht auf eine bestimmte Menge an Bitcoin kaufen
, die von Bergleuten produziert wird, die
geprüft werden
Maschinen, die sie behaupten  zu haben, dass sie
mit der Art von Energie betrieben werden
, die sie behaupten, indem Sie
ihre Stromrechnungen im Grunde überprüfen, oder
dass sie Wärme so verbrauchen, wie
sie es behaupten, also lassen Sie einen externen
Wirtschaftsprüfer sagen  Die Hash-Rate ist da Die
Hash-Power ist da Die Maschinen sind
da Der Strom ist von der Art
, die sie sagen, und er ist
nachweislich grün Sie wissen, dass er
nachweislich grün und nicht konkurrenzfähig ist Er
treibt die Strompreise anderswo nicht in die Höhe
Wir setzen eine Obergrenze  Für die qualifizierende Hash-Rate
legen wir eine Obergrenze für den Strompreis fest, den
sie zahlen, um sicherzustellen, dass sie nicht
mit ähm Einzelhandelskunden konkurrieren, also
nehmen Sie im Grunde genommen die Art und Weise, wie
Bitcoin-Mining gut sein kann, und die
Art des Lohns  was schlecht sein könnte, und
Sie haben eine Checkliste und Sie überprüfen, ob
es gut ist, und dann kaufen Sie die Rechte an
allen Bitcoins, die über einen bestimmten
Zeitraum mit dieser qualifizierenden Hash-
Rate produziert wurden
, die ein Wertpapier ist, das es hat
als solche registriert zu werden I I Ich bin nicht
daran interessiert, die Hash-Rate zu tokenisieren und
sie auf unregulierte Weise zu verkaufen,
obwohl dies weltweit geschieht. Ich werde das
nicht tun, äh, es ist eine Sicherheit,
also muss ich durch die Kanäle
von gehen  herauszufinden, wie es aussieht
, ein registriertes Wertpapier auf den Markt zu bringen
, das dies sowohl in den USA als auch in
Europa tut
Was die anderen beiden betrifft, so weit wie die anderen beiden Ideen, die ich aufgezogen habe.
Ja, genau, ich möchte nicht voreilig handeln,
weil äh, ich möchte äh Peter
McCormick äh und was für Bitcoin wissen Sie
, diese beiden brechen lassen, äh, ich habe auch
Ich interviewe mich auch selbst, äh,
die beiden Leute, die die beiden
fraglichen Unternehmen leiten,
lassen Sie es uns nur einen wirklich zweideutigen
Scherz geben und sagen wir, beide haben
mit innovativen und überraschenden Wegen zu tun,
den Bergbauprozess selbst
zu nutzen  Umweltfreundlich einer von ihnen
und ich  Ich werde es einfach so necken.
Einer von ihnen. Ich werde es so necken.
Okay,
äh,
Bitcoin-Bindung
wird verwendet
, um Wasser zu reinigen
, um reines Wasser zu machen
Sie wissen, dass in die IPCC-Modelle eingebaut
ist, dass wir insbesondere nach 2050,
um die Temperaturen
auf Sie wissen 1,5
zu senken, weil wir überschießen werden,
Milliarden Tonnen CO2 aus
der Atmosphäre entfernen müssen, und dies scheint immer so zu sein
Für mich ist es absolut lächerlich,
eigentlich bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob diese Idee überhaupt
funktioniert,
ähm, riesige Fanbanken zu bauen
und sie an zufälligen Orten auf
der ganzen Welt zu platzieren. Dies wird auch ein
ortsunabhängiges Geschäft sein
, das diese Fanbanken mit
Strom versorgt, der Umgebungsluft durchbläst
Eine wässrige Lösung, die auch
Wärme benötigt, erfordert eine enorme
Menge an Energie und Ressourcen,
aber vielleicht fällt Ihnen etwas
anderes ein
, das Wärme erzeugt und große
Fa-Banken verbraucht  ns
ausserhalb der Kosten neunzig Prozent der Kosten
von mindestens einigen dieser Arten von
CO2-Abscheidungsgeräten
bläst Luft,
die Energie und Materialien, um Luft zu blasen.
Okay, ich würde es dabei belassen, ja,
Teppichabscheidung und Wasser,
ja, reines Wasser, ja,
ja, könnte sein  erleichtert
durch Bitcoin-Mining und bleiben Sie dran
, es ist erstaunlich, ja, das ist, äh, mein
springender Punkt dieses Interviews, auch
nur zu zeigen, wie Bitcoin-Mining die
Kreativität in dieser ganzen
Energieinfrastruktur auf der Welt
anregt und wie man es intelligenter und nützlicher
für die Umwelt machen kann für unsere  Energiekosten,
wenn jemand pragmatisch darüber nachdenkt,
und ja, ich denke, wir haben hier ein gutes
Gespräch geführt, Troy, ja,
das Fazit zum Thema Bitcoin
als Bitcoin-Mining als Industrie ist, dass
es sich um eine
brandneue Technologieplattform für Innovationen
handelt, die Energie verbraucht  Auf eine neue Art und Weise war
noch nie etwas so flexibel wie ein
Verbraucheranbieter. Ich habe nicht einmal erwähnt, dass
Bitcoin-Miner in Sekundenschnelle ein- und ausschalten können
Richtig, was
es ihnen ermöglicht, Netze auszugleichen,
aber es bedeutet auch, ja, wenn die
Strompreise steigen, können Bitcoin-Miner
sofort abschalten oder abschalten, was
bedeutet, dass Bitcoin
-Mining mit anderen industriellen Prozessen zusammenfallen und ein Teil davon sein kann
, äh  ohne
diese anderen Prozesse zu betonen, also
wo auch immer Sie jetzt Heizung verwenden, sagen wir, wo immer
Sie Heizung verwenden,
es ist elektrische Heizung, die
Widerstandsheizung ist, wir können einen Asic
anstelle dieser
Widerstandsheizung einbauen und es muss nicht immer hoch
sein  Mal muss es nicht ständig laufen,
es stellt keine wirklichen Anforderungen,
es kann diese Form des Heizens nur
billiger machen
und ebenso, wenn Sie bereits
Methan verbrennen oder Energie verbrennen und diese nur
verschwenden, wie wir beim Öl sind  Feldern
auf der ganzen Welt verbrennen wir
siebenmal so viel Energie in Ölfeldern,
indem wir sie einfach verbrennen, als das gesamte
Bitcoin-Mining-Netzwerk verbraucht, sodass Sie
sich einen Bitcoin-Miner als eine
subventionierte Heizung vorstellen können  oder Sie können
es sich als einen Fackelstapel vorstellen
, der von Bitcoin subventioniert wird und sehr
effizient effizienter brennt als
vorhandene Flyerstapel und auch
billiger ist, weil er von dem gedruckten Bitcoin subventioniert wird,
wenn Sie anfangen, darüber
nachzudenken
Sie wissen, dass Ihre Vorstellungskraft wild läuft und
Sie erkennen, dass wir erst am
Anfang einer technologischen
Revolution stehen. Wie können wir das Netz verbessern?
Wie können wir Energiesysteme bauen? Wie können wir
Heizsysteme verbessern
?
Eine starke Meinung
über eine aufstrebende Plattform für
innovative Technologie
in ihrer Entstehungsphase in ihrer
Anfangsphase wäre dumm, richtig,
Sie haben eine brandneue Plattform für
Innovation,
wie können Sie eine starke
negative Schlussfolgerung ziehen, oh, wir sollten sie verbieten,
oh, oh, es ist schlecht  für die Umwelt, wenn
wir noch nicht einmal wissen, wie es aussehen wird,
äh, was für Dinge werden obendrein
erfunden, ja, wenn es uns helfen kann, zu reinigen
Wasser, wenn es uns helfen kann, Methan zu mindern
, kann es uns helfen, stark
intermittierende und unzuverlässige Netze auszugleichen, wenn es
uns helfen kann
, äh Formen der Energieerzeugung zu
monetarisieren  tiefe geothermische Rechte
wie die Subventionierung von Kernenergie, äh das
Potenzial
, diese Technologie in
große und sogar unvorhergesehene Entwicklungen
in der Geschichte des menschlichen Fortschritts mit
Energie zu integrieren, äh, Sie wissen es, für mich ist es, äh,
zutiefst
pessimistisch und absurd, auch nur einen
Str zu zeichnen, um eine starke Moral zu haben  Haltung zu
etwas, das wir noch nicht einmal richtig
verstehen,
es scheint mir viel mehr so, als ob die
richtige Einstellung eine des vorsichtigen
Optimismus ist, das Gute in dieser Technologie zu suchen
und es dann
nicht nur zu suchen, sondern zu versuchen,
es richtig zu entwickeln  wo das Schürfen Ihrer
Werte die richtige Unterstützung darstellt, und drängen Sie
auf die Arten der Anwendung dieser
Technologie, die pro-sozial und
pro-umweltfreundlich sind  Die Forbes mental zu vertreiben, die
nicht verboten sind,
weil es ein freies und offenes Netzwerk ist,
das es verbietet, wird nicht viel
Gutes bewirken, sondern sie durch den
Wettbewerb um eine sehr begrenzte Ressource vertreiben
, das ist im Grunde meine Botschaft, es ist ein großer
Schritt im technologischen Fortschritt der
Arten, wie wir mit Energie und Geld umgehen
und
auf beiden Seiten sind wir keine bloßen Zuschauer,
wir sind Teilnehmer und wir können
dieses Narrativ gestalten oder wir können an der
Seitenlinie stehen und uns darüber beschweren,
und ich denke, ich habe die Wahl zwischen
diesen beiden  Ist
ja klar ja wir in Bayern hatten im
19. Jahrhundert einen König der dachte das
Zugfahren nicht so toll ist und
deswegen haben wir im
Vergleich zu anderen Städten in
Deutschland keinen schönen Hauptbahnhof ja
und äh das ist ja so  Wir sehen einfach
, dass Revolutionen immer
von Kritik begleitet werden, viel
Kritik und ich finde es einfach toll, dass wir
als Menschen zusammenkommen können, um darüber zu sprechen
unsere Zeit als Philosophen
und gehen Sie jedes Argument durch und überlegen Sie
genau, ob es Sinn macht oder nicht,
und das versuche ich auch zu sagen, das ist
wie meine Botschaft hier, es kann positiv sein,
wir müssen darüber nachdenken, warum und wie
es nicht so ist  sicher, aber das
Potenzial davon ist so gigantisch, dass
ich auch
meine Zeit für dieses Thema einsetzen und meine Zeit jetzt nur mit diesem Thema verbringen möchte, und ja,
ich meine, ja, und wenn ich Ihren Zuhörern noch eine letzte Sache sagen kann,
ähm,
Sie wissen, ich fühle mich wie ich  Ich habe es heute überstürzt,
und dies ist nur die Oberfläche
einer schwierigen, nuancierten und tiefen Untersuchung.
Je mehr ich darüber gelernt habe, wie
Stromnetze funktionieren, wie Energiesysteme funktionieren, auch wenn
Methan abfackelt, ist kein sehr
kompliziertes Thema, wie Fackeln funktionieren, ich fange
gerade erst an  Um es zu
begreifen,
ähm, Sie kennen die vielen Teile der
Technosphäre, die von Bitcoin berührt werden,
jeder von ihnen repräsentiert
Jahrzehnte menschlichen Einfallsreichtums und
Geschichte und Politik, äh, und ich
erkenne meine Unwissenheit, wenn ich
jeden berühre  dieser Bereiche, was
aufregend ist, aber ich weiß auch, dass normale
Menschen ein Leben zu leben haben, Sie
wissen, dass Sie keine Zeit haben, in jeden dieser Kaninchenlöcher zu gehen,
richtig, aber ich
denke, da ist Ihre Einstellung
genau richtig
Wenn Sie keine Zeit haben, sich über
das Netz zu informieren, und Sie wissen, wie
Strom zwei Drittel davon einfach
verschwendet wird, zwei Drittel unserer Produktion
verschwendet wird, ist es nicht wie andere knappe Güter
, es ist kein einfach austauschbares Gut,
bei dem Energie verbraucht wird  Überall
könnte anderswo verwendet werden, wie wenn
das Bitcoin-Mining-Netzwerk
heute abgeschaltet würde.
Ich denke, die Strompreise würden
definitiv nicht sinken, sie würden
wahrscheinlich an bestimmten Orten steigen, an denen
Bitcoin-Miner für die
Funktion des Netzes hilfreich sind und ein
anderes bereitstellen  Käufer recht und obwohl
sie Energie verbrauchen und das ist
kontraintuitiv und es gibt viele, viel
mehr kontraintuitive
Entdeckungen, uh hier und und angesichts der Tatsache, dass
die Landschaft so spezialisiert ist  d
schwierig und kompliziert Ich denke, die
richtige Einstellung für einen gewöhnlichen
Menschen ist epistemische Demut und
Vorsicht, richtig, es ist genau die richtige
Einstellung,
ähm, Sie wissen, ich bin optimistisch, wie Sie
optimistisch sind, ähm, ich arbeite mit einer Firma
, die das tut  Hilft äh Methanabbau auf Deponiegas dabei
, äh die Abscheidung von Gasen zu finanzieren
, die gerade entweichen
und dann äh diese Gase durch eine Turbine laufen lassen,
um Strom zu erzeugen,
und dann werden wir diesen Strom für
andere Dinge als Bitcoin verwenden, wenn diese
Deponien an die angeschlossen sind  Grid, aber
das könnte noch eine Weile dauern. Ich denke,
was diese Firma mit der Geschwindigkeitsenergie macht,
ist enorm
aufregend  Fragen Ich denke, das ist die
ultimative Lektion zum Mitnehmen. Es ist eine
neue Technologie. Seien wir vorsichtig
damit.
Seien wir auch ähm  Ermitteln Sie
potenzielle Vorteile für die Menschheit mit der
Technologie als Geld und
als Energieverbraucher und
Einnahmequelle in jeder Hinsicht.
Seien wir vorsichtig optimistisch,
erkenntnistheoretisch bescheiden und opportunistisch in Bezug
auf das, was wir finden, um unsere eigenen menschlichen Ziele voranzutreiben.
Ja, perfekt,
ja  Troy, ich würde sagen, lass es uns
hier für das Interview beenden. Vielen Dank,
ich denke, es wird hilfreich sein. Ich hoffe,
ich danke dir so sehr
mehr auf der
philosophischen Seite ein andermal richtig
ja, ich meine, genau das ist eine andere
Sache, die Sie wissen, wie passen Bitcoin und
Philosophie zusammen und wo können wir
philosophische Fragen finden? Ich meine, für mich
ist es wirklich dieses ganze Thema
wie ethische Fragen, Geld und
Ethik  so eng verwandt, wenn es um
Beispiele aus dem wirklichen Leben geht,
dann denke ich wirklich,
ähm, es ist nur ein Forschungsobjekt für die
Philosophie,
es ist nicht unbedingt eth  ical selbst
Bitcoin oder Sie wissen, wie viele Dinge
selbst nicht ethisch sind, sie sind wie
ein Gegenstand der Ethik und ähm, stimme zu. Ich stimme
genau zu, ich denke, Bitcoin ist äh
äh ja, genau ein Gegenstand ethischer Studien
, ähm, wir werden Fragen dazu haben
Sie wissen, wie wir uns auf Bitcoin beziehen sollten,
ähnlich wie wir uns
auf andere Geldinstrumente
beziehen sollten  allen
wichtigen ethischen Fragen
stimme ich voll und ganz zu und ich denke, einige der
wichtigsten Punkte, um die ich
im Frühjahr einen Kurs über Geldphilosophie halte,
und einige der wertvollsten
Aspekte von Bitcoin sind eigentlich nur die Bereitstellung
einer Linse, um genau dieselben Fragen
zu stellen  normales Fiat-Geld,
ähm, Sie könnten es verwenden, Sie wissen, dass Sie es wissen
eine
einfachere Art für mich, über Geld nachzudenken
als die Standard-
Lehrbuch-Denkweise über Geld und
und was richtig oder falsch ist, richtig Sie
denken, sollte die Governance
von
einem Board of Governors durchgeführt werden, die
Vertreter des Bankwesens sind  Industrie
oder sollte es von
Leuten gemacht werden, die einen 200-Knoten auf der
ganzen Welt betreiben, wissen Sie, wer sollte,
wer sollte verantwortlich sein und wie sollte
das gehen, ja Bitcoin hilft mir tatsächlich
, diese Fragen auf eine fruchtbarere
Weise zu stellen